bloody meat juice coming up it's gross i
don't think i could eat this this is
what nightmares are made of yeah it's
kind of scary hey everybody i'm katie
and today i'm going to be testing the
makoni microwavable sandwich grill i'm
going to make a panini and then i'm
going to make a burger in the microwave
so if you guys don't see me
i think we all know why i'm gonna find
out if it works if the food it makes
taste good and if you guys should buy it
okay
let's get to it here at tasty we have
reviewed quite a few kitchen gadgets and
most of them have been pretty
recognizable this one is not it does not
come with a product box so i'm just
gonna jump right in and take this guy
out we've got some instructions which
i'm glad i'm very worried that this is
metal okay well the edges are silicone
so that's good that could go in the
microwave maybe it's not metal maybe
it's more like a
a composite it's very smooth it has a
non-stick like kind of teflon surface i
mean if this works really well this is
saves you a lot of counter space because
the panini press is huge and this guy is
really small you can put this in a
kitchen drawer so space wise thumbs up
okay cooking tips it looks like you can
make the panini but you also can make
fish chicken and steak on this in the
microwave i've defrosted things in the
microwave but i've never fully cooked
something in the microwave that is a raw
meat but you know i'm i'm down to try it
if you go to college this might work
really well for you i feel like that's
what all kitchen gadgets are for just
kids in college i also guys just want to
know that this is a panini sandwich
grill but panini doesn't show up as a
suggested food type till
one two three four five six down the
list so then it says where this food is
between the two microwavable plates the
silicon locks will stretch upwards you
will have to process downwards on the
silicone grill top when locking which i
think they mean you're gonna have to
press downwards well i've got my
instructions which are very limited
mostly about how to clean it i've got my
sandwich maker and now i just need to go
get my supplies and i'm gonna start
making a sandwich okay so i have
everything here that i need to make my
panini sandwich i'm gonna make a pretty
simple one the only thing i'm gonna do
that's kind of spicing it up a bit is
making a spicy aioli so i'm gonna just
add
some mayo because the base of any aioli
is mayo and usually you would have
garlic but i'm not gonna do that for
this we're just gonna do a little bit of
mayo that's a lot of it you can save
this put it in the fridge and then we're
gonna just add some sriracha which i
love sriracha so you do as much as you
want depending on the spice that you can
take for handle you'll get that nice and
mixed up i'm gonna now put this on my
sourdough bread i'm using sourdough
bread a focaccia would be nice or
whatever this is kind of what we had in
the office a sturdier bread especially
since this is going to be going in the
microwave the other thing i usually do
is add tomatoes but i'm just worried
that the tomatoes in the microwave are
going to just get too oozy and wet and
make this really squishy so we're going
to avoid that tomatoes in a panini press
they don't get all the way warm so it's
kind of a really warm sandwich and then
you have that kind of like cool crunch
in the middle what i want to get with
this sandwich is a nice crunch on the
outside very crispy and super oozy on
the inside the cheese really fully
melted and not overly done i want a good
mixture of melted cheese and crispy
toasty bread it's hard for me to imagine
the microwave getting these super crispy
and toasty but we're gonna find out
because i've been proven wrong before so
then the next thing i'm gonna do is i
like a turkey panini a turkey sandwich
you guys can do whatever meat you want
we're just gonna load this guy up i like
a lot of turkey oh my gosh i use like
half this pack that's okay because it's
a protein sandwich and then i'm gonna
use some cheddar cheese i love a little
cheddar and turkey and i'm gonna do a
third slice just because i love cheese
so my sandwich is all assembled in the
instructions said that i needed to
pre-heat this for two minutes so i'm
gonna go pre-heat this and i'll be right
back all right so i just preheated this
thing i can touch the silicone with my
hands it's a little bit warm maybe use
mitts if you need to so let's load in
the
sandwich i guess we're just gonna place
it right there it fits pretty well what
i like about this is it's stretchy
silicone so you could fit a pretty tall
sandwich so there's these little like
locking devices here and you just slip
in the silicone thing i've just this is
precarious though to not touch these
plates okay so he's locked and loaded he
looks good i mean this cheese is
probably going to melt so you might want
to put a plate under it in the microwave
or you can just clean your microwave
plate i'm going to microwave him for
five minutes because it says five to six
in the instructions and i always like to
go under so you can check you can always
add but you cannot take it away we'll
see how it turns out it's dangerous
microwave's done let's pull this baby
out go for it okay hello sir
here we go
set him down right away the cheese it
was like over a microwave so maybe we
could have done a little under the
recommended time because it's almost
like burnie it's crispy so that's not
exactly what you want for your panini
you want it to be maybe a little crisp
but mostly like oozy so we'll see what
the inside's like it's very precarious
because this is very hot but like how to
unlock this maybe i should let it cool
for a minute i'm gonna let it cool
safety first let it cool patience is a
virtue all right he's cooled down a
bunch so i am gonna unlock him oh okay
for a microwave we've got some grill
marks here this did pretty well actually
i'm gonna take them off
we'll give them a cut you know and if
any would like darker lines for a
microwave i'm still pretty impressed
okay
oh
and we got oohs ladies and gentlemen
that looks good it smells a little
microwave like a little plastic
i think that this is pretty good i feel
like we could have even gone a little
bit higher like a little bit more epic
but it really did a nice job squishing
it down and it's got the feel of a
panini so i think all that there is left
to do is to taste this little baby so
i'm gonna give it a go here
my spicy mayo really put that over the
edge okay
so on the second bite the bread is a
little bit chewy so while it's toasty on
the outside it's kind of tough which the
microwave does a lot of the time when
you microwave bread it got toasty but it
also got really chewy so not that nice
like it's not as great as when you get a
hot off a panini press but overall i
mean i wouldn't be mad about it if i
came over to a friend's house and she
was like i made this my microwave i'd be
like good for you
as far as taste i'm gonna give this a b
plus this is making me feel a little bit
more confident about the burger but this
was already pre-cooked like deli meat
and cheese
the burger is gonna be raw meat so i'm
kind of skeptical about how the burger
is gonna taste but why don't we get all
of our ingredients together and we're
gonna try and make a burger in the
microwave okay so we've preheated the
grill for two minutes i have a burger
patty here it's about four ounces this
says to do a eight ounce steak for three
to five minutes it doesn't really say
how to get it to be medium rare how to
make it medium how to make it well done
for our purposes i'm hoping that it's
gonna be medium to well done just so
that i don't get sick so here we go this
guy together
i found that it's easier to do this one
this is on the top so pro tip
do when it's on the top all right i'm
gonna go microwave this for three
minutes and we'll check back in okay so
we put this guy in for three minutes um
very curious to see how this is gonna
look
okay
there's no lines whatsoever of like
grill marks so it definitely is not
getting that grill crispy girly cherry
outside that you would on the grill or
even in like a frying pan it's
definitely really greasy it would be
nice if there was like a dispenser like
a george foreman you know like all the
greases would if there was a way you
could just all come off luckily i put a
plate under it anticipating that this
might happen because there is a lot of
it it definitely would make your
microwave very messy if you didn't do
this it's very
hard which means it's very done but i
can't imagine this being evenly cooked
but maybe it is we'll find out when we
cut into it it kind of has the texture
of like a tv dinner and not a good way
so i'm going to build a burger let's
give them a chance with all the flavors
so we'll just put them right on our bun
i love pickles on my burger so i'm going
to do a couple pickles then we'll do a
nice slice of tomato and some romaine
lettuce and then of course
gotta have some ketchup and mustard i
didn't make any fancy sauce for this
i'm such a child and i'm just gonna put
on this ketchup last but not least some
mustard
and we're gonna put on some mustard nice
just a traditional
burger and we're gonna top that guy
looking lovely and there you have it a
microwave burger how does it taste let's
find out i'm gonna cut into this bad boy
just to make sure that it actually is
cooked all the way through just to make
sure so i don't die okay and well he
looks cooked all the way through there's
like it's a little bit pink but i not in
like a i'm an alarm it looks pretty
pretty cooked taste is what matters here
so let me give them a go
definitely not an amazing burger it's
very rubbery it's lost all of its juice
in the microwave so it's just very chewy
so letter grade i'm gonna give this
about a d plus the panini was so much
better the panini was great what it's
made for it does well i just don't think
you should cook meat in the microwave if
you don't have to we made our sandwich
we made our burger this thing does work
it does make a panini it makes a burger
but not a delicious one so the panini it
tasted good it was crispy the cheese
oozed just like i like it the burger it
was rubbery it didn't taste very good so
we had a b plus a d plus the average
weighted score i don't know if it passed
high school i'm gonna give this product
a thumbs down it costs a lot of money
the product it make tastes okay overall
don't think it's worth it thanks guys
for watching let us know in the comments
if there's a food you like and we'll
find a gadget for it thanks for watching
until next time panini pun i don't have
one oh yes
[Music]
you